hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to show you something extremely
powerful in fact it borders on magic now
what we're going to show you to do is
how to improve and fine tune your vocal
chords and actually improve laryngitis
sore throats hoarseness with your vocal
cords and this is great for if you're a
singer I've been doing this for the last
several years on opera singers from
Juilliard University instructors for
singing vocal coaches singers all over
the place and so what you're going to do
is I'm going to show you how to do this
to someone else and on yourself and
here's what happens a lot of times
people get laryngitis and then they have
to take an antibiotic or take a steroid
and I think that's why a lot of opera
singers are very very large because
steroids have a side effect of weight
gain but steroids are adrenal hormones
and the reason why they do work yet have
side effects is because the adrenal
gland is intimately involved with your
vocal cords they have receptors for
steroids so steroids are adrenal
hormones and so what we want to do is we
want to give you some natural solutions
now this is in no way shape or form used
to a substitute of treating any type of
disease or illness so I'm not claiming
to cure your viruses or your bacterial
infection so that's not what we're doing
but this gives you an alternative okay
so let's say you had a sore throat or
laryngitis or hoarseness or you just
wanted to fine tune your vocal chords
typically what happens is viruses can
come out of remission when you're
stressed and lodge into the vocal cords
and actually cause the whole vocal
chords to shut down to the point where
you can't talk anymore so viruses you
can't kill them because they're not
alive they're a piece of genetic
material wrapped in a sac that come out
of remission and go back in the
remission depending on the state of your
health or stress level so here's how it
works
if we go backwards there's always
something that lowered your immune
system that made you susceptible to
pulling in that virus
or weakening your immune system so
there's always a surly ER stress event
that very few people look at so we have
the stress event lowered immune system
boom you get sick or the virus whatever
the cause is okay so we're not treating
this stuff right here
what we're going to do is remove the
stuck stress that actually lodges in the
throat so we're going to show you how to
do this in the next video and make
mental notes because if you ever have a
learn Jetta sore sore throat apply this
and it usually takes about two minutes
to improve this so it's very very fast
it doesn't have to take a long time and
all we're doing is removing stuck stress
within the vocal chords but we're doing
it in a unique way
so check this out okay so in step one
what we're going to do is we're going to
locate where the person has the sore
throat or laryngitis or a tickle or any
type of hoarseness and usually it's
going to be right down here by the vocal
cords so you're going to have them point
to where it is and then what we're going
to do is we're going to draw a line
around the back of the neck so I'm going
to actually have you sit this way let me
move the chair this way here okay good
all right so we're drawing the line
they're going to point right here we're
going to draw a circle right around the
back of the neck right here and there's
usually a little bump right here okay
and then you're going to come up about
an inch that's right at the back of the
vocal cords so we're going to take our
two fingers our middle finger and our
thumb and we're going to press kind of
down I'm going to take the other head
and stabilize the the forehead as I
press into the opposite part of where
their vocal cords are and the most
important thing you need to do and
remember is make sure you do not mess up
the person's hair and I'm going to hold
this pressure you can see right here I'm
going to push pressure there I'm going
to hold that for about two minutes now
what's interesting about when I do this
is that when you sometimes you're going
to have to be a little higher up because
sometimes their irritation is a little
higher in their neck so you'll start try
to find it where it is and then when you
press the way you know you found it is
it's going to be very
very sore in fact more sore than the
sore throat so there's going to be a
really a hot spot through here so you're
going to press on the soreness use
pressure to their tolerance and you're
going to hold this for about two minutes
okay
and then you're just going to ask them
when the soreness goes away and then you
can stop now if you want to use a device
you can use this on yourself or on
another person this is a device that I
created which is the kind of a
do-it-yourself acupressure device it
looks like this is a tripod because you
could literally put this in the back of
your neck and lay it on a couch or your
pillow on your back and let gravity put
pressure on your neck so with her
because your neck is fairly thin we can
use the real small little spaces right
here if the neck is bigger we can use
this right here so we're going to press
right into this spot here and this makes
it really easy to apply pressure and
we're going to hold this for about two
minutes and it's going to be a little
sore so adjust the pressure based on the
person's tolerance and then you're going
to ask them when that soreness goes away
and if they have laryngitis you're just
going to kind of test it maybe have them
count to ten or something like that and
it's going to improve the quality of
that voice if they have a rasp enos or
they or let's say it's a little little
tickle the key is having a point to
where it is go exactly opposite press
opposite point and hold this for two to
three minutes and you're going to apply
this pressure at least three times a day
for a couple days and that should clear
it up on many cases all it takes is like
1/2 minute
acupressure to actually clear up the
throat so again we're not treating the
virus all we're doing is removing the
blockage by working on the opposite side
of the blockage so go ahead and apply
this send me your comments below this
blog and I will see you in the next
video